can you go through the uh
the four op types sure
um okay so you have unaryops which take
in uh a tensor and return a tensor of
the same size and do some unary up to it
X log uh reciprocal sign right they take
in one and they're pointwise
really yeah value
um almost all activation functions are
unaryops
um some combinations of unaryops
together is still a unaryop
um then you have binary apps binary apps
are like uh Point wise Edition
multiplication division compare uh it
takes in two tensors of equal size and
outputs one tensor
then you have reduce Ops reduce Ops will
like take a three-dimensional tensor and
turn it into a two-dimensional tensor or
three-dimensional tensor turn into Zero
Dimensional tensor things like a sum or
Max are really the common ones there
and then the four type is movement Ops
and moving tops are different from the
other types because they don't actually
require computation they require
different ways to look at memory so that
includes reshapes permutes expands flips
those are the main ones so with that you
have enough to make a map model and
convolutions and every convolution you
can imagine dilated convolution striated
convolutions transposed convolutions
you're right on GitHub about laziness
uh showing a map Mall
matrix multiplication see how despite
the style it is fused into one kernel
with the power of laziness can you
elaborate on this power of laziness sure
so if you type in pytorch a times B plus
c
uh what this is going to do is it's
going to first multiply Adam B A and B
and store that result into memory and
then it is going to add C by reading
that result from memory reading C for
memory and uh writing that out to memory
there is way more loads and stores to
memory than you need there if you don't
actually do a times b as soon as you see
it if you wait
until the user actually realizes that
tensor until the laziness actually
resolves
um you can fuse that plus C this is like
it's the same way Haskell works so uh
what's the process of porting a model
into dynagrad so tiny grad's front end
looks very similar to pytorch
um I probably could make a perfect or
pretty close to perfect interrupt layer
if I really wanted to I think that
there's some things that are nicer about
tiny grad syntax than pytorch but the
front end looks very torch-like you can
also load in Onyx models we have more
Onyx Test passing than core ml
okay so we'll pass Onyx run time soon
what about like the developer experience
of tiny grad
um what it feels like what are the
um
versus pytorch by the way I really like
pie torch I I think that it's actually a
very good piece of software
um I think that they've made a few
different trade-offs and these different
trade-offs are uh where you know tiny
grad takes a different path one of the
biggest differences is it's really easy
to see the kernels that are actually
being sent to the GPU right if you run
pytorch on the GPU
you like do some operation and you don't
know what kernels are in you don't know
how many kernels ran you don't know how
many flops were used you don't know how
much memory accesses were used tiny grad
type debug equals two and it will show
you in this beautiful style
um every kernel that's run
how many flops
and how many bytes
so can you just
Linger on what problem tiny grad solves
tiny grad solves the problem of porting
new ml accelerators quickly
one of the reasons or tons of these
companies now I think um
Sequoia marked graphcore to xero right
cerevis tens torrent uh grock
all of these ml accelerator companies
they built chips the chips were good the
software was terrible uh and part of the
reason is because I think the same
problems happening with dojo
it's really really hard to write a pie
torch port because you have to write 250
kernels and you have to tune them all
for performance